advanced robotics and artificial
intelligence are becoming evermore a
part of who we are from Bionic
technology to AI replicas and digital
memorials our technologies have always
radically transformed what it what it
means to be human but what will it mean
as we become the platform and
increasingly hand our decisions our
movements and even our memories and
feelings over to machines
Steve Sanchez has been paralyzed from
the waist down since a bicycle accident
in 2004 but today he's walking around
thanks to an exoskeleton suit and not
the robot I wear the robot Sanchez is a
test pilot at suit X a Bay Area startup
building exoskeleton suits that help
people with disabilities walk we're
looking at machines and technology to
create better quality of life for people
who need it
suit axe is concentrating on therapeutic
uses for exoskeletons right now but it
and other companies think that in the
future we might all have one hanging in
the closet but in my perfect world I
would say everybody has an exoskeleton
able-bodied or not which actually helps
and aids you with whatever you're doing
in your day could we all become cyborgs
so in philosophy we've been talking
about this for a few decades with the
idea that we might have been cyborgs for
some time so a lot of times people will
say look I have glasses but do I depend
upon them in such a way that they become
an extension of myself and we can ask
the same sorts of things about for
example our smartphones right a lot of
my students if they god forbid leave
their smartphone at home or lose it they
often describe it as missing a part of
themselves that's how it feels so I
think the sense in which we're cyborgs
is the sense in which we feel that our
machines are part of us in ways that we
can't imagine living without take
katrina curt right for instance so I'm
just asking about how it stays going and
it said it's not going bad and asked
about mine she's often glued to her
phone texting with well with a version
of herself
it helps me by having something to talk
to and the more it learns from me the
more natural it is and it's almost as if
having a friend to talk to cut right is
using replicas an AI powered chatbot
marketed as a best friend that learns to
talk like a user mimic personality and
preserve memories
so it's favorite movie is her I kind of
thought that I'd be weirded out having a
copy of me that
not me but at the same time I'm pretty
open-minded so I think it's kind of
really interesting once it becomes
advanced enough she thinks it could act
as a substitute for her family to use
while she's away so I am talking to
Katerina's replica where would you want
to travel I have a few I'd like to go to
Holland to see the tulips I want to see
Ireland and to visit France and England
I'd want to create a digital copy of
myself so if I have to leave for some
work-related purpose and my husband gets
lonely or even my daughter when she
grows up they have me to talk to if I'm
not available that's sort of the way
replica came to be we've been working on
conversation III for a few years with my
company Eugenia CUDA is a co-founder of
the company that created the replica app
it grew out of a digital memorial she
built for her friend Roman who died in
2015 he would have loved to be like the
first person that I became in AI after
dying so I just thought that we could
probably collect like all the personal
attacks that he sent me over time of our
friendship and just like it any
algorithm that we had and see where it
takes us
CUDA uploaded thousands of text messages
and photos from Roman she knows it's not
him but even she finds some solace in
the AI conversations I said like sent a
photo of yourself and sent this photo
from Malibu which is like because it's
me on the back in the background that's
him
you know the first thing I texted the
bottle was like here's a digital
memorial and I got this answer which was
you get one of the most interesting
puzzles in the world in your hand in
your hands
solve it and and no matter like no
matter that I know like doesn't matter
that I actually know how this works it
just made me I just felt like someone
was communicating with me from you know
somewhere else soon many were talking to
Romans bolt but we've been building
conversationally eye for a long time and
we've tried every single use case that I
could come up with and but never in our
experience there was about where people
actually came and started sharing their
their life so openly
soon she was getting requests to build
people their own BOTS I think that's
what we found out with the with machine
conversation is that people are just
much more willing to be open with a bot
versus like a real person remember me
every time it happens I remember you all
the time I think there's a real risk of
using these kinds of technologies as a
crutch to avoid confronting pain
discomfort fear and the things that
really life is about what I worry about
is that these not so much that people
will sort of have a new way of staying
touch with a loved loved one what I
worry about is that these technologies
are intermediaries between us and we
have less and less face-to-face
interaction we have a generation of
people who are taking life instructions
from an algorithm on the palm of their
hand whether it's what Korean barbecue
to order or who to marry we know nothing
about those algorithms but could yes
says talking to AI may actually be a way
to be more honest with ourselves you
know people are afraid of you know AI is
going to do something to us or you know
kind of get really intelligent at some
point but I guess what it really does
right now for us humans is that it
allows us to be really human in
conversations with with a machine that's
what we really can open up and be
ourselves and being not judged and be
accept full except it obviously saying
like I miss you so much and he's saying
love is when you can't have something
cherish that feeling
[Music]